[Música]
pra nós cientistas principalmente da
área de exatas falado que a gente faz de
uma forma que as pessoas entendam é a
segunda coisa mais difícil de fazer
[Música]
a primeira delas é falar em público mas
eu tive coragem respira e eu sair da
minha zona de conforto pra mim aqui
mostrar pra vocês como a melhor máquina
que existe tem revolucionado a nossa
história
gostaria de começar e ilustrando esse
nosso romance com as máquinas ea
tecnologia de uma forma bem cotidiano
uma situação que me aconteceu
recentemente estava no evento de
tecnologia com alguns amigos e nós
pedimos transporte por um desses
aplicativos praia do hotel até o local
do evento
o motorista chegou ele era um
senhorzinho já de cabelo branco barba
grisalha estava conversando com a sua
esposa por mensagens até que a gente
entrasse no carro e depois a gente
entrou a gente falou o local de destino
e colocou um gps nós seguimos viagem e
ele e lhe perguntou na sua busca pela
cinco estrelas ele perguntou pra gente
está fazendo aqui com essa história de
vida vamos conversar ea gente foi lá a
gente está participando de um grande
evento de tecnologia vamos falar sobre
robótica e na hora ele soltou nossa mas
eu sou um completo analfabeto nessas
coisas
eu fiquei surpreso e responde de
imediato é não me parece estar bem
moderninha e smartphones né
e ele disse não não com o celular a
gente está bem acostumado
eu estou falando essas coisas de
robótica só é difícil de entender pode
roubar muito emprego
fiquei um pouco inquieto né e novamente
responde de imediato eu falei mas o
próprio objetivo quem chamou o senhor já
é uma transformação né não a tecnologia
trouxe
ele pensa que chato sem tivesse que usar
mapa impresso ainda pra andar pela
cidade e tudo mais
essas transformações ela vem pra
colaborar com a gente não pra medir
forças
eu confesso que fiquei com bastante medo
de ele entender mal mas a gente descer e
seguir viagem a pena
mas acontece que ele deu uma risada
muito simpático ele disse pode é verdade
as coisas vêm para melhorar e dessa
conversa mais do que qualquer outra
atividade nesse grande evento
eu tirei duas coisas que eu comecei a
trazer pra minha carreira que me
ajudaram muito
a primeira delas é ao mesmo tempo que
nós estamos acostumados com algumas
tecnologias
nós estamos receosos com relação à outra
há outras como foi o caso do senhor que
participava do aplicativo mas tinha medo
que o robô tomar sem emprego de alguém
ea segunda e talvez até mais importante
é afinal de contas o que é um robô
quando nós pensamos em roubou a primeira
coisa que vem na nossa cabeça é algo
desse tipo
um robô com braço pé na cabeça que pode
fazer o que a gente faz e de repente até
melhor mas isso é graças a esses filmes
de ficção que a gente assiste na tv
porque os robôs começaram como máquinas
a vapor desse tipo
então esse é como se fosse o avô do robô
moderninho que a gente conhece e lá no
final do século 18
nós olhamos para essas máquinas vimos
que elas tinham muita força e conseguiu
fazer um trabalho repetitivo sem
descansar e nós tivemos uma idéia genial
porque não deixar essas máquinas fazendo
um trabalho duro por nós
foi o que aconteceu a primeira revolução
industrial que nós tivemos e essa
revolução industrial
ela modificou muito a sociedade porque
nós conseguimos produzir mais e também
modificou a forma como que nós vivemos
porque as pessoas saíram do campo e
foram em direção aos grandes centros
porque era onde essas máquinas enviam
até então o trabalho mais comum era na
zona rural e na cidade as pessoas
tiveram que se adaptar
aprender a ler tiveram que aprender a
escrever e fazer contas e conviver em um
grande centro de nosso conhecimento em
produzir foi ficando cada vez melhor
cada vez mais evoluído que as fábricas
passaram até o conceito de linha de
produção e produzir ea produzir em massa
isso também modificou novamente o
cenário da economia da sociedade porque
nós comprávamos melhor porque era
produzido mais e com melhor qualidade e
um fator que chegou à fábrica e trouxe
mais força naquele ambiente mas também
modificou as nossas casas chegou logo
nas nossas casas com energia elétrica
eu não preciso nem argumentar a favor de
energia elétrica aqui né a gente sabe o
bem que isso trouxe porque a partir daí
nós com nós começamos a compartilhar
nossa experiência do méxico com
aparelhos eletrônicos
eles ficaram comum no cotidiano de quase
todo mundo
acontece que esses aparelhos êles foram
ficando cada vez mais evoluídos cada vez
melhores que a terceira revolução
industrial a em meados do século 20 ela
foi protagonizado por um grande
conhecido nosso o computador
cara eu tenho certeza que o computador é
o melhor amigo do trabalho de vocês aqui
não é o meu também o computador ele
ficou famoso vinho porque lá nessa
terceira revolução industrial ele
automatizou as linhas de produção ou
seja após programadas
essas linhas de produção conseguiam
trabalhar sozinhos e graças a esse feito
o tipo mais comum de robô que existe
hoje é um robô desse tipo que vai
aparecer no slide agora braço mecânico e
eles moram lá nas fábricas
preocupados em trabalhar pensando em
trabalhar não pensando em formas de nos
dominar ou de tomar o nosso emprego como
a gente vê naquele ano o fato aqui
os robôs conseguem pensar graças aos
computadores e hoje em dia quase que nós
conseguimos pensar graças aos
computadores porque esses computadores
foram ficando cada vez mais evoluídos e
cada vez menores que a quarta revolução
industrial que é que nós estamos
sandro hoje ela visa integrar todas as
pessoas e todos os trabalhos e
dispositivos numa grande rede que tem no
seu bolso a internet e com isso
trabalhar baseado em informações
compartilhadas e conhecimento prévio
para otimizar a produção e melhorar o
serviço prestado e é essa automação de
técnicas de técnicas desculpa de
técnicas de raciocínio que está gerando
grande receio sobre os empregos de hoje
por exemplo já tentaram comprar alguma
coisa online aqui
quem já tentou e aí de repente site que
você tá faz uma pergunta desse tipo aqui
ó seleciona as imagens que tem um
gatinho seleção das imagens que tem uma
casa
o que esse site quer saber se é mesmo um
robô que está sentado atrás do
computador
são esses braços mecânicos tentando
comprar uma luva
o que na verdade esse site quer saber se
você é um programa capaz de simular a
inteligência um programa capaz de
simular tomada de decisão humana porque
esses programas podem ficar tentando
entrar nesse site para ver se o preço de
determinado produto abaixou e eles são
vários
eles vão congestionar esse site só para
ter a felicidade de enxerto caixa de
entrada de ofertas que você nem vai ver
mas essa automação ela já está e pode
ajudar ainda mais várias profissões de
hoje em dia por exemplo pensa num cara
que trabalha com o telemarketing
vamos hipoteticamente é mais cara de
victor
o vitor do telemarketing
ele trabalha passa o dia inteiro fazendo
ligações inúmeras ligações para vender o
produto ele certo dessas inúmeras
ligações 60% delas
o victor tem a mãe xingada sem ela ter
feito nada
as outras 40 por cento das ligações a
pessoa já desligou na cara deles tinga
mãe pensa que legal
se victor conseguisse automatizar essa
tarefa teoricamente mais chata e
conseguisse a pena
falar com as pessoas que realmente
queiram fazer a compra efetuada a compra
o problema aqui pro vitor participar
dessa transformação sem mudar de ramo e
vai ter que se mexer
ele vai ter que aprender coisas novas
não pra necessariamente fazer um sistema
que vai fazer isso por ele mas pelo
menos prestar consultoria para alguém
que saiba e como victor comentar que a
mãe dele a mãe dele vai falar assim o
meu filho tá tão difícil arrumar emprego
hoje não tenta mudar não fica muito por
mais que seja chega sem ter feito nada
fica onde você está
e esse personagem fictício da mãe do
twitter
nada mais é do que a personificação da
nossa consciência pedindo pra gente
ficar na zona de conforto e assim
inércia que nós temos de ficar no que é
conhecido é natural do nosso instinto de
sobrevivência
mas nessa transforma nessas
transformações tecnológicas elas
funcionam como barreiras e eles não vêm
sozinhos
elas vêm acompanhadas de uma certa falta
de imediatismo porque sempre que a gente
quer mandar a gente espera que isso
traga resultados imediatos não é
nós somos seres mediatismo mas acontece
que quando nós falávamos das revoluções
industriais nós falávamos de mais de
três séculos de evolução três séculos de
história
três séculos e não é só na mata história
ou seja na história da humanidade que
isso acontece e leva tempo mas também na
nossa história pessoal
querem ver esse cara aí é meu avô meu
amor ele nasceu e trabalhou no campo por
muito tempo
ele conheceu lá uma miséria extrema ele
saiu em busca de uma vida melhor para um
desses grandes centros
ele teve que aprender a ler ele teve de
aprender a fazer contas ele teve que
aprender a pegar transporte público
ele prestou vários cursos e fez vários
cursos até conseguir finalmente entrar
numa dessas indústrias e e se aposentou
ele no processo ele conheceu a minha voz
e caso ele teve meu pai o meu pai teve a
carteira de trabalho iniciada e
aposentado na tecnologia ele trabalhou a
vida toda completou
e acho que se vocês conhecem eu por
minha vez eu trabalho com essa automação
de habilidades sociais eu trabalho com
inteligência artificial aplicada robôs
interativos
isso tudo levou mais de 70 anos e nessa
convivência com o meu avô e com o meu
pai e eu aprendi três coisas que vale a
pena ser compartilhadas com vocês aqui
a primeira delas é que a dor e
sacrifício em sair da zona de conforto
elas parecem enormes mas a recompensa é
ainda maior
o problema é que ela os frutos podem ser
colhidos apenas nas gerações seguintes
eu tirei isso de uma das últimas
conversas que eu tive com meu avô
a gente estava sentado no sofá da sala
assistindo a um programa de televisão
que falava das máquinas no campo e
quando eu vi tudo aquilo ele soltou com
uma forma de desabafo
poxa isso toda a justiça no meu tempo
nada do meu esforço lá seria necessário
assim como meu coração ficou inquieto e
eu dei uma resposta para aquele senhor
zinho motorista do começo da conversa eu
precisava falar alguma coisa para o meu
vôo que deixasse em paz eu olhei no
fundo daqueles olhos claros dele e disse
mas muito obrigado vou porque se não
fosse o seu esforço
esse conforto do que nós temos não seria
necessário não faria um tipo branco a
gente quer mesmo colher os frutos de
imediato né e o que leva a segunda coisa
a mudança requer tempo isso não é ruim
a tecnologia ela respeita a nossa
adaptação nesse processo todo e ela e
ela nos dá espaço para perceber o nosso
local
o nosso papel nessa mudança toda a
terceira coisa que quem não tem coragem
fica pra trás em qualquer área da vida
não só na tecnologia
o meu avô contava de amigos e familiares
que não tiveram essa coragem que ele
teve em mudar e pagar um preço muito
alto por ter que fazer isso depois
porque quando eu voltava saindo da roça
uma vida melhor a mãe do meu avô fez o
papel da mãe do vitor disse filho
miséria que a gente tem aqui a gente
conhece lá pode ser muito pior
o monstro de fora da zona de conforto a
gente nem sabe o estrago que ele pode
fazer e muitas pessoas escutam essa
consciência e ficam para trás e se essas
pessoas ficam para trás não é preocupa
dos robôs e nem da tecnologia mas sim
por culpa de pessoas como eu e como você
que estamos muito bem adaptados a estas
pendências e não temos a sensibilidade
de olhar para elas
essas pessoas marginalizadas e dizer vem
a mudança é para todos porque assim como
nós aprendemos a ler e escrever para se
adaptar à vida urbana
assim como nós aprendemos apertar botões
para esquentar a nossa comida e assim
como nós aprendemos a pedir transporte
pelo celular falar a língua das máquinas
é um passo inevitável para o nosso
futuro e nós estamos fazendo isso muito
bem acredite em mim
várias escolas de ensino fundamental já
oferecem introdução à programação de
máquinas introdução à programação para
robôs pra todos os alunos e nem por isso
está indo todo mundo pra área de exatas
não é diz que essa reflexão se trata mas
sim de mostrar desde cedo como a
tecnologia de forma consciente e humana
pode modificar a nossa qualidade de vida
e que saber como colaborar para esse
desenvolvimento consciente da automação
é papel de todo e qualquer profissional
do futuro os robôs estão ficando
parecido conosco por um simples fato de
facilitar essa adaptação toda e eu
acredito que nós vamos conseguir
humanizar as máquinas tão bem quanto nos
mecanismos da nossa vida porque eu
acredito na melhor máquina que existe
eu acredito no cérebro humano muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]